Move on,
straight up,
move on.
Forget them.
They are lying and they are untrustworthy.
So move on.
Now sometimes this can be hard,
especially if they've somehow tied themselves into your life.
Especially like for instance,
you get the kids involved in a divorce scenario,
you can't move on,
but you have to mentally move on.
You have to emotionally detach from that human,
and that's hard to do because obviously they were someone that you trusted be.
And the reason I know that you trusted them is because they got to a point where
they were able to be true your and destroy you.
So they they,
it's hard,
but the fact that they trust that you trusted them,
the fact that you had that relationship,
that's even more reason to walk away.
It's even more reason to move on.
You've got to see them for
what they are.
And this is an important piece right here.
This is an important cause.
This is something I learned as a young lad out there in the world.
That person is not who you thought they were,
right?
They are not who you thought they were.
The idea that this person was a trustworthy,
faithful companion is not true.
It is not true.
That person does not exist.
They didn't exist and they don't exist.
It was in your head.
It was in your head that this person was trustworthy and you the,
they were everything you wanted them to be and they were faithful command.
That is a lie.
They are not.
That person
may have proved it.
They've proved it by their actions,
so move on and at the risk of sounding callous,
get over it.
Get over it.
Do not dwell.
Do not dwell on to not dwell on,
on on what it was and don't dwell on what it could have been you who you are.
When guys go through bad breakups,
you know it's,
I just thought we were going to,
it's like,
no,
don't dwell on that.
Deal with what it is right now,
what that person is.
Deal with reality except reality and be be thankful for reality.
Be Thankful that you were able to learn before you invested more into this
person.
Be Be.
Be Thankful that you found out when you did that this person was a liar,
that this person was unfaithful,
is untrustworthy.
Be Thankful
that you know it and you know it now instead of later.
And you know what else is going to make it a lot easier to get over these
situations is recognize that there's plenty of people out there in the world
that are trustworthy and there are faithful good people.
They're out there.
Go find one of them.
But
don't think that that person that you had was the only one in the world.
They're not.
And you know what if that sometimes,
sometimes people have a hard time making that trust because they're so caught up
and they,
they,
they don't want to meet someone else right away.
That's fine.
Start with yourself,
right?
Rely on yourself.
Trust yourself.
Because we,
when,
when someone breaks our trust,
we,
we questioned ourselves too.
Like we think are my judgments bad.
I'm not a good judge of human character cause I totally put my faith in this
person and look what they did to me.
So now we don't trust our,
so you've got to build that trust up.
You've got to build that trust up back again with yourself.
How do you do that?
Read
right?
Learn,
workout,
be alone.
It's okay to be alone.
Some people get freaked out when they're alone.
It's okay.
It's okay to be alone.
There's no big deal.
Enjoy it.
Do something productive and build that trust up in yourself.
You know,
look back at a situation and learn from it.
We do that and I'll post operational debrief.
Oh,
you've put too much trust in somebody.
Cool.
They broke your heart.
All right,
Roger that.
Let's see,
what would the steps,
what should I have recognized?
How many times did I say,
well,
you know,
they didn't call me,
but it's probably just because their phone was out of battery.
No.
Once your phone runs out of battery once,
okay,
you don't let it happen again,
right?
So you start seeing those red flags so you the mistakes that you made and then
look for them next time around because you deal with people all the time that
they made mistakes.
The first run,
they go back and they make the same mistakes.
The second run,
they go back and make the same mistakes.
The third run,
that's when you've got to start blaming yourself on your situation.
That's why,
that's why I said you got to like build a relationship with yourself.
You've got to learn yourself.
You've got to trust,
got to learn to trust yourself.
So spend some time doing that.
And
then when you go back and you start dealing with people,
because that's what,
that's what you got to watch out for,
is that you become a hardened criminal.
You don't trust anybody.
Like you were talking about cops.
You know sometimes cops have a hard time because they're dealing with scumbags
all day long and it builds up this,
this mistrust of other people.
So you don't want to have that happen.
You want to be suspicious of people,
but you want to be able to build trust once they've proven themselves.
So take those small steps and start to build up over time.
Don't just jump in and give someone a hundred percent trust out of the gate.
You don't know him.
Don't know him.
You know back in the day,
back in the day with old hardcore bands used to have this t shirt that just said
trust.
No one was like,
yeah,
that's legit.
Right.
You don't,
don't go out of the gate with the big trust on somebody with important stuff.
Don't do it.
But the good news is,
like I said,
there's plenty of people out there that are good people that you are give you,
you can give all your trust to just take it slow brother.
Yeah.
It's so crazy how you just explained that so simple and it makes total sense
when you're in the situation though all the motions,
you know like you can't just detach and be like,
what are the red flags that I didn't know you're too busy missing
person or whatever your disaster
thing was.
Looking at pictures,
that's the worst.
You have to get out the picture and stare.
I've seen guys doing that.
I'm like Bro,
give me that.
Let me fill this away for you.
It's not going to help.
That person that I was always to me was,
was explaining like,
listen,
cause guys,
which she was,
no,
she wasn't.
That is a lie.
That person that you put put together in your head that you've assembled in your
mind,
that person doesn't exist.
They don't exist.
The person that you dealt with was a liar,
was the unfaithful,
was a cheater.
That's the person.
The person wasn't this person that you're putting forth in your mind.
That person doesn't exist.
So stop,
but you don't understand the good times.
Yeah,
I know.
It's a,
here's the trick.
Okay.
So
if,
okay,
that person a liar,
that per the cheater and what I kind of said there,
it was like you don't understand the good time.
That's a real part of it.
That's really it.
It's like sure they did this.
Sure sheet.
Um,
uh,
flats,
my tires when she gets measure all that.
But the good times we have are so good.
So it's,
it's,
it's proof that it,
it's not about the person.
It's not about the person that you can see all the red flags and how they
mistreat you from time to time or they beach.
It's about yourself and how you're sad now because of all these reasons.
But the trick comes with what one of the tricks come with.
Um,
same thing I said about drinking,
where it's your brain.
Cause it's like chemicals.
When you bond with someone in certain,
in certain ways.
And it's different from,
you know,
it varies from person to person,
but it's like,
I think it's like oxytocin or I don't know,
something where it's,
it's,
it basically,
yeah.
So I want to go into,
but you feel this bond with this specific person.
That's why you have these feelings.
Even though this girl like lies to you,
you see her lying text messages on your phone right now.
You're looking at him.
Meanwhile you still,
I still miss them.
It's a trick because it's saying like that your emotional wellbeing is attached
to this person kind of thing.
Right.
And all the other stuff,
you just kind of ignore it.
So it just like,
um,
how was the same with drinking?
Right?
Why?
No.
Consciously like,
I'm going to be hung over tomorrow.
I won't get anything done.
All this stuff,
but why do I want to drink so bad right now?
You know,
kind of thing.
Um,
and it's the same thing.
The chemicals your brain are telling you
like this girl is essential for you.
You know,
for your wellbeing's not,
yeah.
Oh,
that's the magic though.
That's a lie.
It's a trick.
I'll listen to them.
Don't listen to your brain.
Listen to me.
She's not essential,
bro.
I'm telling you the,
but that's the logic.
Those chemicals were blocking.
I have seen so many situations where guys are just in,
what's horrible is,
I'm sitting here saying this,
it's,
you could be smacking someone in the face,
telling them,
move on,
and they're not going to listen.
That's all.
So you got to make that decision.
Yeah,
that's,
it's hard.
And guys ruined their lives.
I mean the others due do two girls and guys,
they ruin their lives,
you know,
with over somebody that is completely abusive,
whether mentally or physically that just completely abusive and they'll ruin
their lives for this person,
that person and see in my mind,
I think it's because they build a person,
they build a person on the framework of reality.
They build a fantasy and they're in love with that fantasy and they want to keep
it going.
It's a fantasy.
So stop and they get away ignore like all the Quona version for sure.
And they remember the good times,
even if it's like 10 minutes a week,
they remember those good times.
They ignore the red flags foot because of that,
that you know that trick,
that chemical truck in their brain.
So it reinforces that thing that they built,
you know that fantasy that they built it.
It's true.
It's this big,
the reality is this big and look the fantasy and they just attached to it.
You ever see like a friend or whatever,
cause I'm assuming you've never been in this situation like you ever had a
friend where they're really into it.
They're almost ruining their life,
they're in bad shape or whatever,
and then whether it be all of a sudden are years later,
whatever they're thinking back and they're like,
whoa.
Was I think because of the chemical trick so to speak,
wears off and then they can see all that logic that you're talking about.
You're like,
oh my gosh man.
It's,
it's almost like,
it's almost like you feel like you were a different person when you recovered
from cancer and just the fact that you can't talk any sense into people and
they're in that situation is the trick.
You got to try and,
yeah,
it's hard.
It's hard,
but I think knowing that that's it.
It's a chemical in your brain that is tricking you and it goes for a lot of
stuff.
Donuts,
like all this stuff.
It's tricking you if you know like,
Hey,
and you say,
I'm not going to be tricked.
I feel it.
I feel this,
that I feel the sadness.
They feel missing this person,
but it's a trick,
you know?
That's,
that helps.
It totally helps.
I like it.
So move on man.
I know it's hard.
Trust us.
Speaking of moving on,
next question,
unless we want to talk about this tomorrow.
No,
I think you're exactly right.
Let's move on.
In what circumstances do you recommend direct?
I will hold on.
Oh,
we're not moving and you're stuck on it.
But what's horrible is men,
people killed themselves in these situations.
Yes.
Over a lie.
Yeah.
That's,
that's,
to me,
that's the trick.
But it's a lie it in guys or girls get so distraught over this fantasy that
doesn't exist.
And what's really jacked up is if they could just move on,
they'd find a reality that was actually congruent with what their desires are.
And it's out there.
You can see people all over the world.
They're there,
they're in relationships or having fun from every level.
Right?
There's someone out there,
but you,
you get caught up in this mental trap and,
and obsessing over a fantasy.
It's a fantasy.
Don't,
don't,
don't obsess.
Over the fantasy,
man.
There's,
you can,
you can get over it.
And there's plenty of other human beings out there that are awesome.
So go find one of them.
And in the meantime,
hang out with your Badass self,
right.
And become a better person.
And working out is a big one for sure.
For sure.
That's the 100% just get it,
get in the gym and get after it.
Jujitsu solves everything.
This lifting solves every day.
All right.